انصار الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد في الشارع
للتعبير عن دعمهم لاجراءاته وخطواته هنا
تردد نفس شعارات الرئيس محاسبه الفاسدين
والخونه ورفض التدخل الاجنبي لانه اعتداء
على سياده تونس النابعه من اراده الشعب
لكن هذه الشعارات لن تمنع الجهات الاجنبيه
المختلفه من الحديث عن الوضع في تونس كما
هو الشان هنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه
المره تضاف الى النقاش الازمه التي نجمت
عن تصريحات الرئيس التونسي الاخير بشان
المهاجرين من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
انه وضع اقتصادي وسياسي مؤلم تواجه تونس
وضعا يترافق فيه عدم الاستقرار السياسي مع
وضع اقتصادي مزر لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي بالاضافه الى
ذلك فهنالك تصريحات غير المقبوله بشان
المهاجرين من جنوب الصحراء الكبرى
يشير بورد هنا الى مفاوضات تونس مع صندوق
النقد الدولي للحصول على ق في قيمه مليار
وتسعمائه مليون دولار كانت متعثره فنقلتها
تصريحات سعيد بشان المهاجرين الى وضع اسوا
تحاول ايطاليا المتخوفه من تدفق موجه طالب
اللجوء على شواطئها قادمين من تونس اقناع
حلفائها الغربيين بتسهيل حصول تونس على
القرض لكن جهودها تصطدم بمواقف عده دول
تريد ان ترى اصلاحات في تونس الولايات
المتحده طالبت بهذه الاصلاحات عده مرات في
اخر تصريحات الامريكيه قال وزير الخارجيه
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم التطلعات
الشعب التونسي الى مستقبل ديمقراطي مزدهر
ودعم الجهود القائمه لحمايه حقوق الانسان
وسياده القانون قبل ذلك وبعد الانتخابات
الاخيره ونسبه المشاركه المتدنيه اكدت
واشنطن اهميه تبني اصلاحات شامله وشفافه
بما في ذلك تمكن هيئه تشريعيه المنتخبه
وانشاء المحكمه الدستوريه وحمايه حقوق
الانسان
وبعد حمله الاعتقالات في صفوف معارض سعيد
عبر المتحدث باسم الخارج الامريكيه عن قلق
الولايات المتحده الشديد ازاء تقارير عن
اعتقال شخصيات سياسيه ورجال اعمال
وصحافيين في تونس رد الرئيس التونسي على
الانتقادات الغربيه وقال ان تونس دوله
مستقله ذات السياده وليس تحت الاستعمار
وانه يعلم جيدا ما يقوم به في ظل احترام
القانون تحاول الدول الغربيه ابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه مع السلطه في تونس وتبدي
فرنسا وايطاليا مرونه في التعامل معها لكن
دولا غربيه اخرى على راسها الولايات
المتحده لا تخفي امتعاضها من اسلوب الرئيس
سعيد في التعامل مع شؤون البلاد